it's a little segment here what would
you like a rap about shoehorn Thank You
ventriloquist in this section shoehorn
now this section really what would you
like a rap about shoehorn is the first
suggestion surfing surfing gets
suggested a substantial amount here in
Hermosa so I'm not going to take that
sorry hospital administration
yay night out forget about the job and
then some goody two-shoes is like a
hospital administration hospital
administration shoehorn this side cuz
that side you had you go with shoehorn
this side here what you want to rap
about catheters okay I can see where
that came from
or Anzio kind of implanted that and you
like they did to him it's very exciting
catheters hospital administration
shoehorns this wedge here the magna
carta
oh very fancy and cool everyone else
just going we don't know what that is
the magna carta obviously obviously I
know what it is but for the benefit
everyone here do you want to give him a
little brief pressing on the Magna Carta
I knew all that as well
amazing the Magna Carta signed by King
John to foster relations of the British
people in 1215 runnymede I've been to
running mint it's pretty boring so let's
let's give the guys over here who aren't
the person who said shoehorn what would
you like a rough about one second what
did you say you said a wanker
now I heard you say I just got you to
repeat it because to me there's nothing
funnier than an American saying the word
wanker
because wanker sounds great in an
English accent when an American says it
it sounds horrible it sounds like it's a
nasty thing
wanker oh I don't like it
someone said something at the back which
was a bit more erudite what was it
Aladdin thank you for that one
Aladdin will take a London Aladdin have
you seen the new movie one person has
another person just when I don't like it
with the movie or the fact that a white
guy is about to rap we'll find out we'll
find out so Aladdin shoehorn hospital
administration the Magna Carta what was
our final one that we and the catheter
amazing you're too late with Shakespeare
there I'm afraid unless you misheard
catheter is kind of close so this then
lovely people the comedy magic club a
little treat for you guys to close out
the night a little thing called a
freestyle made up on the spot about all
those things and don't worry it won't be
anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly toe-curling ly bad as you
are expecting it to be some of you seem
very unconvinced can we drop that beat
let's give them a little little
freestyle I'm excited and none of you
are apparently
[Music]
where to begin I've got a Bigfoot
everyday a shoehorn it in I've gotta fit
inside my sneakers my boots and my
slippers my feet are too big so you know
they won't fit average shoe size and is
different in the EU be UK you have to
add one to the size of the shoe you can
read it but if I take it off I won't get
it back on again
I just professed I say the truth when I
talk about shoes I'm going in to a shoe
shop yes I'd like to use the shoehorn I
get one side of me I get it car from an
elephant ivory now how'd you fit a
little tube up there don't use a
shoehorn for a catheter the holes not
big enough you're tearing open make the
patient upset when their penis is broken
split in two so frustrated looking like
a kangaroo because it's bifurcated did
you know that's the fat about my soup
appeals if you did it in the hospital
they would sue you're a catheter yeah
I'm a fly dude I don't wear nappies I
just use a tube I walk around there I'm
a fancy lad you can see me strolling by
with my catheter bag I like to swing
around and if you step to me I'm gonna
slap you around the face how wet you'll
be with the urine spraying out of the
sides need to keep the seems little blob
down ty next thin yeah move with speed
to the South of England I'm down and
runnymede where King John he was there
for the start yeah signing all of the
Magna Carta everybody have a look not as
good as the Doomsday Book but when it
comes to history lessons I get off the
hook the only person who's amused is
this guy he is like Guerra suggested it
why would you say that
yeah historical trying that go off to
Agrabah run I'm watching Aladdin I like
the Anna made one by Walt Disney Robin
Williams he was the genie now we got
Will Smith and it's real live action the
trailer he was painted blue a hideous
action it ruined my childhood or my
memories I want to fly with aladdin and
Jasmine please she's the best princess
she's the one I like I was like you can
come into my palace tonight she's in an
hourglass I just see from afar I'm like
I'll save you smash it with the staff of
Jafar if you've seen the film the
cartoon one that's what happens haven't
seen the remake the real one who are
berlad in the next thing that we're
gonna do I'm sorry that we couldn't say
wanker for you but that's okay I can
stay all day son tapping on a keyboard
in administration
I do the task Yara do all cuz I'm the
best
admin in the hospital I do admissions
and also when I let the patients go I'll
work on the market inside and make it
grow more people needing more appendices
our peritonitis when it explodes inside
how in admin yeah you get your reward
hoping patients like me run Zeo don't
steal the clipboard making sure you're
giving them permission people come in in
the kind of friction that you face when
you're dealing with insurance forms the
standing in front of you every time you
warn them to say check with your
provider this ain't my job suggesting
administration for a wrap is kind of odd
but really I must thank you because it
really was a wanker that is not a nice
thing no I'm I spanked you not actually
because that's not something I would do
and not the hospital but the comedy club
would then be sued
[Applause]